if you like The Odd Couple yeah
that's a good show idea great show idea
being visiting in a sitcom real I'm
being real because I have I'm on a show
now but no one's watching it helps
splitting up together two ABC Family
show thank you and it's been on for two
years and no one's watching it I like to
show a lot but how you getting paid I am
getting paid and um but yeah I'm joking
but that would be a great I'm being real
but would you just single camera or a
live audience single live audience
probably Walter Kerr would be
interesting multicam would be fun would
you do in front of a live audience a TV
show I've never done something like that
but yeah I mean I would yeah let's do it
let's write the show yeah but is it an
interesting thing you know media maybe
we're brother let's talk about yeah wait
yeah we're adopted brothers okay yeah
and how old are you Michael
39:39 younger bro we were the first the
first ok here's what is 47 so this is
the show right now you're okay so your
parents right they that's the problem
what is your background no what is your
in I can do a [ __ ] American accent so
well you can yeah and be judged by the
[ __ ] what is it they're the followers
or something yeah yeah yeah what'd he
call the Reapers the sleepers yeah or it
could be that he was adopted it's a
cryin family no to an English family
right and he came back I don't know and
they were murdered but I was the first
your our parents didn't think that they
could have a biological kid yeah they
adopted me first and then years later
our mother
pregnant with him right and he went out
and he lived a great life he was like
maybe some military thing or he was in
the Navy or whatever right you see a war
hero okay but I'm the loser stationed in
England
you're a hikikomori you're a shut-in I'm
a gamer I'm a gamer loser and you have
to move yeah I'm a loser you play that
yeah there's something there yeah
together they'll be funny let's do it
let's do yeah
[Music]